قبل اسبوع من الذكرى الاولى للحرب الروسيه
في اوكرانيا عقد وزراء دفاع حلف الناتو
اجتماعا لمناقشه قرارات الامدادات
العسكريه التي سترسل الى اوكرانيا الامين
العام للحلف شدد على ضروره تزويد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه التي تحتاجها لكسب هذه الحرب كما
اشار الى اهميه مناقشه انواع الانظمه التي
سيتم ارسالها الى كييف
انها مساله الطائرات ليست عاجله الا ان
النقاشات متواصله وكما قلت من قبل
المشاورات مستمره بين الحلفاء حول نوع
الانظمه والاسلحه التي يجب على الحلفاء
توفرها لاوكرانيا
وزير الدفاع الامريكي قال ان روسيا
تراهنوا على انقسام النيتو وانه يجب تكثيف
الدعم العسكري وتلبيه احتياجات اوكرانيا
المرحه وتزويدها بانظمه الدفاع الجوي
والدبابات
لدى اوكرانيا متطلبات عاجله لمساعدتها على
مواجهه هذه اللحظه الحاسمه في مسار الحرب
الرئيس
اكد على حاجه كياب لمزيد من المعدات في
اجتماعنا الاخير
روسيا من جهتها اشارت الى ان الناتو اصبح
يشارك بشكل متزايد في الحرب في اوكرانيا
حلف الناتو منظمه معاديه لنا وهي تظهر هذا
العداء يوميا حلف الاطلسي يحاول جاهدا حتى
يكون وقوفه الى جانب اوكرانيا واضحا جدا
وبدا الجيش الالماني في تدريب جنود
اوكرانيين على استخدام الدبابات القتاليه
من طراز
الحكومه الالمانيه كانت وعدت بتسليم كياف
اربعه عشره دبابه من نفس الط